tinker kitchen is for anybody who likes
to cook who want to be able to do stuff
that they can't do at home we're almost
like a real-life version of the Iron
Chef set but with a community that
explores food and cooking together this
great big story is brought to you by
Delta when we venture out into the world
we see all that we share my name is Dan
Mills and I'm the founder of tinker
kitchen relaunched in October of 2018
we're a maker space where people can
come together to cook for fun or to
prototype ideas for new food products
before I had tinker kitchen I was
collecting kitchen equipment at home my
wife was very supportive and she allowed
me to expand the kitchen into the living
room but then I realized that I actually
wanted more kitchen equipment that I
could fit the idea came to us to open a
kitchen space that anybody could come to
and then we could share all of the
kitchen equipment and we could get even
bigger and better things
tinker kitchen is kind of like a gym in
that we're a space that has a lot of
machines that once you become a member
of the space you can come and you can
use for whatever you like maybe they
want to use freeze dryer to freeze dry
some food or maybe they want to use deep
fryer to fry some food maybe they want
to make chocolate from being the bar or
a dehydrator or making fruit leathers or
chips what else oh we have we have a
grain mill so we've had people who come
here to build their own flour and then
make bread and they have a very nice
blowtorch with a series of attachment
that you can use to sear just about
anything and sometimes I use it to make
myself a real tea sandwich I like to
cook everything like I'd love to extrude
pasta but I also like other very sciency
things for example making ice cream with
liquid nitrogen
it tickles my nerdy roots I love to be
here when there are other people around
making cool things sometimes I'm the
beneficiary from being able to taste
things that people make one thing that
was surprising is just how many people
there are that are interested in in
cooking and cooking together even with
people that they didn't know beforehand
I feel like I've found my tribe these
are people who understand my nerdy
impulses to like really understand the
science of food so that's pretty
exciting to find people who are just
like me
[Music]